[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous racontez une histoire une fidélité
des mensonges une blague
vous allez voir j'ai besoin de votre
votre aise mental mais aussi physique
alors je vous demande de fermer les yeux
pendant 5 secondes
et pendant ce temps là vous allez penser
vous êtes tous départ se fait à gauche
par la droite
tout ce noir et blanc derrière des
pingouins
alors vous êtes une colonie de pingouins
en france vous êtes sur glacier tous
ensemble comme y vivent et se relâcher
et l arrivée dans la seine ça c'est la
scène j'ai la scène ici dans la poubelle
alors y adhéreront terrain c'est le mal
il ya d'un plus petit c'est laid les
femmes
et puis là et l'appétit donc c'est les
petits pingouins alors le matin le
soleil se lève sur le glacier et les
petits 10 moment on a faim à paris l'ont
fait alors un certain moment vous touche
tous les parents il saute dans l'eau
dans la seine il faut savoir ce qu'ils
mangent ils mangent du scr il inscrire
cette petite grave des petites crevettes
des méduses alors les petits savent pas
ce que c'est alors ils descendent à yann
heures qui dit quelle belle mais du jld
ils ne mangent y en a un autre qui vit à
moi j'ai trouvé une petite crevette
bleus ça n'existe pas mais bon ils le
mangent et vous connaissez l'histoire
pour maintenant là vous êtes en
antarctique
tous les pingouins de limoges je voudrai
vous expliquer il faut qu'on retourne
maintenant dans mon passé
on va arrêter les 50 ans alors la
décision les 50 secondes c'est quoi une
seconde visuel c'est peut-être ça petit
cube c'est un cube 40 ans ça fait le
théâtre rempli même l'image pour ampli
mais ces conditions beaucoup plus donc
je rempli presque toute la france à des
étudiants en 68 69
la révolte des étudiants je voulais
devenir artiste est passé dans la
musique avant donc d'arriver dans les
musées il faut est unique et il faut
faire du bon travail
bon ça c'est secondaire un musée c'est
quoi c'est un bâtiment qui conserve une
boîte en soupe c'est quoi c'est une
conserver qui concerne la soupe ça pue
la même chose alors au début j'ai dit
bon ben faut que je trouve un matériel
qui est évident qui sera pour l'éternité
qui seul à conserver pour l'éternité
alors il ya 50 ans j'ai rencontré des
ingénieurs qui commençait à faire des
bateaux en résine dans la résine san
oxydes pas te pu le mettre dans l'eau
donc c'est un produit qui est pour
l'éternité
norman ans la philosophie qui est
derrière ça vient d'eux ou la résine
ça vient de l'huile et l'huile c'est
quoi c'est un fossile organique
pessiot de plantes et d'animaux et là
vous avez là le truc qui peut énormément
il ya des gaz qui sortent maintenant
quand on craque la molécule en chimie
d'un côté les gasol de benzine qui sont
la cause la pollution quand on les brûle
depuis des années et de l'autre côté des
produits synthétiques avec ses produits
synthétiques ont produit mes lunettes
les boutons de ma chemise la peinture le
plastique des nouveaux fossiles la même
chose ces nouveaux fossiles sont pour
l'éternité
alors mes premiers fossiles je prenais
un pain lui répond je mettais des
couches transparent de de résine dessus
et j'avais crié une sculpture qu'on
pouvait plus manger mais dans mille ans
si on va retrouver ces fossiles et vont
dire là ils vont prendre des pilules
pour le pain mais ils vont trouver le
vêtement parce qu'il y en aura plus
donc c'était ça mon but la démarche qui
est derrière la philosophie qui est de
faire des sculptures
je faisais la même chose avec des habits
genève était en résine voit la sculpture
un peu d'animaux dessus pour faire la
décoration et on était parti mon
entourage
à ce moment là les années 70 c'était le
conceptuel alors la photo était très
important à ce moment alors je me disais
les photos une photo ça une vie limitée
cent cinquante ans et ça disparaît alors
je vais trouver la solution
jeudi vont je vais le mettre en désigne
des coups des deux côtés
tous les ans télé et je les fais pendant
10 ans on a déterré et les photos
étaient intactes donc j'avais prouvé que
je pouvais faire des faux cils pour
l'éternité dans le petit koala derrière
moi il ya un autre facile c'est ma grand
mère
alors jamais fossilisés ma propre vie
mon histoire personnelle avec ma grand
mère elle aide les gens âgés alors que
vous allez la voir là elle faisait de
gymnastique avec une copine de moi et je
mettais les photos en résine aux petits
comme dans les bd photo du marché aux
puces
ma grand mère une copine à moi même même
habit donc des fossiles pour l'éternité
là on a subi un grand mère fait le
peintre alors là il dit neige n'en a
jamais fait la vakaga disons nord j'ai
travaillé des années des années des
années avec mon modèle préféré c'était
pas que la audiard ou naomie ces
différences dans la voilà les cieux
c'est comme si vous allez chez le
bijoutier haut mais la photo la photo
dans la ouate elle reste assise sur la
terre elle va décider un jour alors les
années 85
je trouve des autres inspirations dans
le monde entier
dans mon entourage la vache folle en
anglais fed en a tué 30 millions de
vaches parce que c'était dangereux de le
manger
alors moi j'ai trouvé une solution j'ai
dit voilà madame je vais prendre au
petit chien
je vais rester génétiquement je vais
l'agrandir ça y'a pas de problème alors
je faisais des chiens géants font les
clowns et après comme ça il faut plus
donné dormant me d'antibiotiques et vous
avez de la viande que vous n'avez plus
des vaches voilà des grands chiens ils
trouvent ça il y en a comme ça j'en ai
emmené il n'est pas très grand bombay
parce que ma voiture était trop petit
à rome un tout gros chien avec de
grandes crocodiles ce qui est normal
donc la nourriture pour feature l'autre
côté de la médaille
par exemple en afrique il fait trop
chaud alors tous les grands animaux ils
vont mourir ou bien ils vont se laisser
se rétrécir en plus petit sa selle
darwinisme mais ça prend 100 mille ans
alors moi je vais l'échangé
génétiquement et je vais faire des
petits éléphants le petit éléphant
on va l'élever et ça sera le poulet pour
le dimanche imaginez ces salles artistes
la petite girafe dans votre livre
enfin bon je pige dans le cochon il fait
chaud pour lui mettre des bottes
vous allez dans le midi à la plage à
midi il faut m'aider flip flop
non sinon tu celui là dans l'abbaye
j'ai fait des installations je ne fais
pas qu'un petit chien
j'en fais des centaines pour faire des
installations à ses granges une autre
matière le cargo qui ont transporté
l'huile ils sont recyclés en inde en
turquie
l'empereur cuivre et ils me font des
chiens en bronze c'est pas du quartier
mais c'est le même métal tu vas y à
chaque fois le petit peu de sarcasmes
dans ce que je fais installation en
uruguay en uruguay ya des personnes qui
sont immigrées et c'est vrai en plus en
hiver ils sont là le relâche des
migrants plein soleil un peu plus grand
avec une bouteille dur sur le dos alors
la bouteille c'est le symbole de l'eau
potable qui quand ça continue comme ça
cela en danger il y en aura plus c'est
pour ça que je mets sur tous les animaux
et beaucoup de mes objets des bouteilles
d'eau une autre histoire longue primaire
un médecin je vais l'amener chez le pape
il a trois bouteilles d'eau sur le dos
si ce message est dispersée dans le
monde
je touche en deux semaines 2 milliard de
personnes
coca cola ne s'est pas fait à madonna
non plus suite le oui ça c'est marketing
je crois que j'ai fait mon temps alors
j'espère que vous allez faire quelque
chose pour sauver la planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]